[Musique]
bonjour charlotte gressier or une
parachutée une arriviste une qui n'y
connait rien les mots avaient été très
dur à votre encontre au lendemain de
votre désignation pour être la référente
de la république qui en marche ici en
martinique une semaine après vous en
êtes vous remise de ce flot d'attaqués
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
je n'ai pas eu le sentiment finville des
attaques peut-être mais vous savez le
mot parachutage le trouve sévère et non
avenue dans la mesure où on ne peut pas
dire aux jeunes de revenir ce qui est
mon cas de revenir au pays et en même
temps leur dire qu'ils sont parachutés
ça me paraît un peu contradictoire
on aurait pu imaginer un autre baptême
du feu car le plus dur reste à faire
notamment pour vous installer le parti
présidentiel ici dans notre île porter
cette parole du parti au pouvoir
quelles sont vos priorités là les
priorités c'est donc de faire un
diagnostic parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
de solutions opérationnelles pensée dans
l'intérêt général de monter des projets
également ce qui est aussi le cas
mais comme vous le savez avant même
d'imaginer des solutions possibles il
faut faire un diagnostic qui soit claire
et qui viennent aussi de la base donc
ils veulent des martiniquais c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle on
lancera donc prochainement une plate
forme de consultation auprès des
martiniquais plate forme de consultation
en plus de toutes les remontées que le
gouvernement attend à travers ces
assises de l'outre-mer oui jugé pour
diverses plateformes
on a jugé que c'était utile cette
opération qu'on a appelé l'opération
umoja savent de manière à ce que chaque
martiniquais puisse réellement et sans
tabou puisque ces faits dans l'anonymat
aussi de faire remonter toutes les
injustices alors objective qu'ils
pensent les empêcher d'accéder à
l'épanouissement personnel dans cl ça
existe de telles remontée d'informations
depuis des années oui pourquoi en faire
encore de nouveaux de de nouvelles
consultations larges et vous avez raison
j'ai connu les états généraux de
l'outre-mer en 2009 comme tout le monde
j'ai même participé à la mise en place
d'un audiotel par thématiques dans
l'anonymat pour que la société civile
puissent exprimer l'avis d'autres
initiatives génération watts et oui et
7,7 audiotel avait donné lieu à un
rapport que j'avais même remonter
jusqu'aux conseiller
l'outre-mer du président de la
république de l'époque
effectivement si on arrive aujourd'hui
aux assises c'est qu'il n'y a rien
concrètement qui a été fait jusqu'à
présent
donc vous avez raison et mais moi j'y
crois encore alors c'est peut-être les
gens pêche ma tête par live thé mais j'y
crois encore il ya en croit la démarche
des manuels macro et de son premier
ministre de la république en marche
serait plus productives alors comme vous
j'ai été très méfiante je n'ai jamais
caché très méfiante jusqu'à ce que
j'entende le discours du président de la
république à la source donc sans
commentaire aux commentaires de
commentaire et là en fait j'ai vu
simplement un espoir un espoir de
transformation pas simplement de réforme
mais de transformation et une écoute une
semblait qu'il y avait une écoute
possible ce qui est déjà énorme pour
partir sur de bonnes bases
donc à partir de ce moment là j'avoue
que j'ai été
j'ai été convaincue de cet élan et que
je me suis dit on ne peut plus continuer
comme ça en martinique je ne suis pas la
seule à constater le vieillissement de
la population l'exode aussi enfin vous
avez 2000 à 3000 personnes par an qui
partent de martinique c'est pas normal
et quand on sait tous que la martinique
peut apporter au monde je dirais que le
discours lors de la conférence la 22e
conférence des régions
ultrapériphériques en guyane à la fin du
mois j'appelle tous les martiniquais à
la réécouter mais à la source
parce que là on montre alors les régions
ultrapériphériques je n'aime pas trop ce
mot là dessus au moins 2 vous avez évité
de dire métropole aussi un métropole
alors hexagone c'est ce qu'on dit c'est
vrai mais région très périphérique c'est
un terme un peu barbare qui pour les
gens qui nous écoutent intègre des îles
portugaises et espagnoles aussi des îles
françaises dont la martinique
effectivement là j'ai entendu dans ce
discours que les régions
ultrapériphériques notamment françaises
lui parler d'europe océanique française
d'ailleurs pouvaient être des solutions
pour la france pour l'europe et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez alors en tout
en toute franchise sourire lorsqu'on
entend ça parce que il ya pas qu
emmanuel macron avoir dit ça non en
revanche non non c'est vrai mais bon
entre dire des choses et les faire je
prends l'exemple très simple suite à
cette conférence
il s'est quand même adressé au président
la commission
européenne suivie d'une guerre et c'est
comme passer à la trappe
mais il ya eu cette possibilité de
financement pour le renouvellement des
flottes ultramarines notamment pour la
guyane
bon on en a parlé comme ça en question
politique locale suivent
est-ce que quel est votre regard sur ce
qui se passe en martinique de point de
vue politique
alors puisque vous êtes de nouveau une
nouvelle formation politique des forces
et mon regard sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui même déjà la première chose
c'est la gouvernance ce que je suis
convaincu maintenant pour avoir
travaillé pour l'outre-mer en tout cas
en essayant de travailler depuis des
années qu aucun projet aussi pertinent
soit-il projets économiques notamment
n'aura un impact positif à long terme
s'il n'est pas fondée sur une
gouvernance assainies il s'est fait
happer ce n'est pas le cas en ce moment
je pense qu'il ya des choses à revoir
quoi par exemple alors il ya des la
question de la gestion de l'argent
public qui est une vraie question de
savoir qui est responsable de quoi
et pour faire quoi et avec quel budget
aussi je pense que l'identification
clairement doit être accessible à tous
en tant que porteur de projet gelé et et
c'est pas forcément simple de savoir à
qui s'adresser lorsque vous avez le
coeur de monter un projet dans l'intérêt
général est en tout cas pour la
martinique
par exemple vous imaginez par exemple
tous ceux qui vous écoutent tous ceux
qui sont à la tête de formation
politique ou de collectivités qui sera
la ctmb les communautés d'agglomération
ou même les municipalités doivent à vous
écouter avec le sourire elle est jeune
elle commence j'ai rencontré pour
coacher des bouts de bois la piste si
chaud alors j'ai quand même enfin jeu
c'est vrai que je parais jeunes c'est ça
le piège j'ai 33 ans je les ai tous
rencontrés j'ai rencontré tout le monde
localement à l'époque c'était même des
conseils conseil régional conseil
général à l'époque
donc j'ai tout rencontrer les
institutions locales qui est au niveau
national mais même au niveau européen
résultat des courses et ben je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est que
idrissi n'ont pas répondu à vos attentes
c'est le signe les attentes
elles sont simples en fait vous avez un
exemple très simple c'est l'accès à des
chiffres les statistiques ou des études
économiques
réactualisé qui permettrait à quiconque
veut monter un projet de pouvoir le
faire ça c'est ce serait une demande
je sais que les choses sont en train de
se mettre en place mais pas assez vite
selon vous pardon pas assez vite
non pas assez vite ce après bon c'est
complexe mais il ya des choses qui
auraient pu être mises en place
notamment je vous parlais de ces
chiffres là j'ai lu dernièrement une
étude sur le tourisme et innovation qui
portait la réunion en exemple et qui
regrettait que qu'il ya un manque
crucial d'études note par exemple sur
l'hôtellerie
et ça c'est vraiment dommage parce que
encore une fois on voit que lors des
dernières assises c'est le tourisme qui
était qui a été mise porté aux nues
oui et par tourisme je pense d'ailleurs
qu'il faut pas juste s'arrêter au
tourisme balnéaire qui est très
important mais que
il s'agit de défendre tous produits
économiques d'exception en martinique
et il y en a charlotte gré si on aura
l'occasion de revenir avec une autre
fois parce que nous sommes déjà pris par
le temps sur ce que vous comptez faire à
horizon 2020 2021 puisqu'il y aura des
municipales et et les collectivités
territoriales de martinique à 2021
vous allez vous implanté de façon
durable partout rapidement ou oui c'est
une question de crédibilité de sérieux
dans la mesure où nous n'avons personne
encore donc la représentativité est
évidente donc oui nous préparons aussi
parallèlement les municipales bien sûr
que vous serez présent dans toutes les
communes de martinique
oui nous essaierons en tout cas en
essayant de voir comment on peut
discuter aussi avec les mairies en place
mais on fera tout pour être présents
puisqu'ils sortent avec des personnes
novell pas des opportunistes d
opportunisme et des personnes qui seront
en quête d'un second souffle mais
écoutez je ne céderai rien moi mon
intérêt c'est celui de la martinique
donc ceux qui seront contre moi ça sera
contre les martiniquais et on sera très
vigilants à atouts saboteurs ou sous
marins merci beaucoup charles ii si on
rappelle que vous êtes la référence
martinique de la république en marche
bonne journée
[Musique]